these ruins are all that's left of the
Catholic church in anyangee where two
thousand Tutsis sword shelter a mass
graveyard Testament to what happened to
them
the man responsible for their killing
full Jean's kayashima has now been
arrested at a Vineyard in South Africa
a reward of 5 million U.S dollars had
been offered for help in leading to his
arrest
the former police officer was hiding
under a false name for 22 years
rwanda's genocide was unprecedented over
100 days about eight hundred thousand
minority Tutsis and moderate hutus were
killed by Hutu militias
kaiashima is accused of buying petrol
used to burn down the church while
refugees were inside and then bulldozing
the building after the fire
ibuka an umbrella Association of
genocide survivors in Rwanda has
welcomed the erased it's
a great relief for a Booker for the
survivors of the genocide who have been
crying for justice for years and years
so it's a very positive thing especially
at this time of commemoration
kaishima had already been indicted by
the United Nations criminal Tribunal for
Rwanda
the UN says its Secretary General
Antonio gutierrez's thoughts are with
the families of the victims Mr
kaishima's apprehension sends a powerful
message that those who are alleged to
have committed such crimes cannot evade
Justice and will eventually be held
accountable even more than a quarter
Century later
it's widely hoped that the arrest will
help bring closure to victims families
created the wounds created a trauma so
and during the genocide people like
fusions
behaved as if there was more gods in
front of the truths that they were
killing so when survivors see such a
person who behave like a small God being
taken to Justice at least
to them that that's also it's it's it's
it's a hearing uh event
kaishima will be appearing in a court in
Cape Town on Friday but securing an
extradition is a long and laborious task
people like naftali believed just as
delayed is Justice denied
we afraid that these people could die
without facing justice so we really need
to do this quickly the United Nations is
still searching for at least three more
key suspects in the Rwandan genocide
but for now this arrest brings hope to
the loved ones of some of those who died
in what's been called one of the most
serious crimes known to humankind Andrea
van wyk Al Jazeera